[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime opera and welcome to my review
of chapter 162 of the boku no hero manga
as always spoilers will follow if you
enjoyed these reviews and want me to
keep making more be sure to leave a like
to let me know and if you're new to the
channel I want to be notified every time
I'll put on a new review don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
I honestly had no idea how they were
gonna follow up on the previous chapter
knowing what happened to certain I died
but this short chapter was quite good a
lot of important things happen we
learned that while Depp when the others
were fighting over Hall and the eight
precepts Gran Torino and Su kouchi were
in the mountains trying to hunt down
Kuro kitty this confirms that even
though they were focused on the eight
precepts the pro heroes and the police
did not forget the legal villains and
they were trying to catch up to them as
well as Gran Torino and the police
tracked down Kuro kitty
he tells them that he is looking for a
certain ruffian apparently all-4-one had
foreseen the future and he instructed
Karogi to protect shigaraki if anything
happened to him but according to Corgi
be shigaraki is not the only one that
all-4-one was cultivating this other
that Kuro kitty is looking for is
supposed to be all for once faithful
servant that the League of villains can
rely on and his name apparently is
giganto machia now began to makea is the
war that was fought between the gods of
Olympus and the Titans or the Giants in
Greek mythology so it is safe to assume
that this began to machia villain is an
incredibly powerful giant of some sort
and you can see from the one image that
we did get that he is as tall as a tree
and he appears to have a giant
electronic device around his neck I
don't know what this device is but maybe
it's a way for the league of villains to
control him somehow
I am wondering why Kudo getti calls this
villain a ruffian I'm wondering why he's
wandering around the mountains has this
device around his
heck I'm starting to think that maybe
he's not old they're mentally and when
guru Kimmy says that he is a servant of
all for one he might actually mean that
he is a sort of no mood type mindless
servant I'm also wondering if the device
around his neck is some sort of tracking
device and he's essentially like a wild
animal that needs to be tamed so that
the villains can use them to their
advantage
I am definitely looking forward to
learning more about this villain he
looks very badass and extremely
dangerous
back in the city the next morning the
police has been humiliated for letting
shigaraki get to overhaul on their watch
and of course the villains were able to
steal the bullets and the serum which is
a huge blow to the police in the
hospital deck who meets with me do who
has been asked to stay in the hospital
for another day for observation after
how he looked in the last chapter
absolutely devastated by the death of
sir Knight I we all expected to see me
do still completely depressed and full
of sorrow
however surprisingly me do seem to be
back to his old cheery and energetic
self deck who is obviously taken by
surprise that after losing his quark and
his mentor sir Knight I me do is
actually smiling but me do says that
that is exactly why he is smiling sir
one and him to smile and to go on to
become an outstanding hero and that is
exactly what media intends to do media
also knows that if he has a glum face
then it will make Eddie and other people
that depend on him feel even worse and
that's not how a hero should be a hero
has to help others feel better you
really have to love and respect how
strong and determined media is
definitely an incredible role model for
the other students deku then goes into
one of his customary self-doubting
tantrums saying how me do should have
been the one to inherit one for all and
if he did sir would still be alive and
all this stuff and while I'm reading
this I'm thinking dude Deku you're a
student who just defeated freaking
overhaul and saved the day chill out
will you you did an exceptional job you
couldn't possibly have done more and me
do pretty much tells Deku the same thing
that he did great and he needs to relax
as these chapters go on I'm really
finding myself liking and
affecting media more and more definitely
a great character media also mentions
that if area learns to control her
quirks she might be able to restore his
quirk by rewinding his body to the point
before he lost it but personally I think
that it will be a long time before any
master search work and in my opinion it
is more likely the media will restore
his work by taking the serum that
overhaul created sometime in the future
even though the league of villains
currently has this serum so that makes
things more complicated the chapter ends
with a glimpse of Bakugan and Todoroki
going to their provisional license
course and I'm glad we finally get to
see these guys again after so many
chapters Todoroki is one of my
absolutely favorite characters so I
missed him a lot in these last few
chapters and I also think that he and
baka go together could have done a lot
of damage to the eight precepts so it's
a shame that they couldn't take part in
the raid at any rate I'm looking forward
to seeing these guys again in the coming
chapters basically where we're at now is
that the league of villains is clearly
becoming the central threat once again I
am very curious learn more about this
guy canto machina new villain what is
his deal is he able to control himself
or is he under the control of the
villains what is he going to do what
kind of role is he going to play
also what is shigeki going to do with
the bullets with the serum where is that
part of the story going I can't wait to
find out let me know down in the
comments what you thought of this
chapter where you think the story is
going from here what do you think of
meteos incredible strength as a
character and also are you happy to see
Baku grow and pull the rocky back in the
game if you enjoy these reviews and want
me to make more be sure to leave a like
to let me know and if you want to be
notified every time I upload a new
review be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell as always thank you so
much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]